se logró el esperado 30 por 30 que
aspira a proteger el 30% de la tierra y
los océanos a 2030 y que greenpeace
Iguala al límite de uno coma cinco
grados Celsius de calentamiento global y
el otro es el reconocimiento de los
pueblos indígenas en ese sentido Cuáles
son los avances que plantea este acuerdo
sí creo que uno de los principales
Creo que este es un muy buen acuerdo
para los pueblos indígenas de hecho así
lo han expresado los pueblos indígenas
han logrado poner lenguaje sobre sus
derechos en sus tierras y derechos
relacionados a sus culturas en gran
parte del acuerdo y Esta es una victoria
rotunda teniendo en cuenta Cuáles fueron
las primeras comparaciones con respecto
al acuerdo
Creo que este es lo primero para decir
los segundos también es un un buen
acuerdo para todo lo que son la
planificaciones espacial de todos los
de todos los las áreas para proteger
aunque también es cierto que es
insuficiente porque de hecho la ciencia
está pidiendo un 50% de protección del
planeta y no un 30% como se se acordó
pero igual es porque de esa única manera
para poder llegar al límite del 1.5 de
grados centígrados es justamente
proteger a las 50 por ciento y no el 30%
como el ipcc pero es un acuerdo que
mucha gente lo lo valora y y que es un
acuerdo en lo cual es una base para
poder Poner este en marcha protecciones
ambiciosas de los ecosistemas y este
acuerdo culming Monreal llega en
reemplazo de las metas ahíchi que
vencieron en 2020 y que no se cumplieron
con ese antecedentes se necesitaban
entonces mecanismos claros de
implementación Pero por qué no se
lograron
no se lograron porque no tenían metas
cuantificables no se lograron porque no
habían acuerdos claros de implementación
Y no se lograron porque tampoco había
acuerdos políticos eso de alguna manera
se se salga con otras con otras
conversaciones en este contexto donde
por un lado nos encontramos con acuerdos
más políticos por otro lado nos
encontramos Cometa más cuantificables no
solamente en términos de tiempos pero
también en Cómo se haría esto con
mecanismos también de mediciones mucho
más específicos que se acordaron en todo
este proceso y por otro lado también
se ponen como metas también de
financiamiento que también son
importantes porque Esto justamente puede
movilizar a la acción con una manera
mucho más fuerte entonces creo que los
acuerdos de aychi fueron acuerdos muy
ambiciosos que no se cumplieron debido a
que no habían mecanismos de
implementación claros los cuales nadie
se hacía responsable porque no de
ninguna manera de ponerlos en la mesa Sí
y hablando de financiación este acuerdo
dice que los países desarrollados
destinarán 200 mil millones de dólares
por año a las naciones en desarrollo
esto para proteger la biodiversidad sin
embargo desde organizaciones como abas
donde usted trabaja consideran que no es
suficiente por qué
porque también Así es económica nos dice
que necesitamos proteger Primero estamos
proteger más áreas esto significa
proteger más áreas significa obviamente
poner más dinero y por otro lado también
lo que hay que hacer es hacer un hay que
redireccionamiento de fondos porque
existen una enorme cantidad de fondos
que son dañinos para los ecosistemas
según los estudios que nosotros hemos
este analizado se necesitan un trillón
de dólares cada año que no es una cifra
muy alta Más allá de que así lo parezca
ser un billón de dólares Perdón en
español
este billón de dólares no es una cifra
tan alta teniendo en cuenta que
que los países necesitan mantenerse en
en una cifra
teniendo en cuenta que la biodiversidad
es este
es la base de la economía mundial no
entonces Este creo que los economistas
son muy claros que se necesitan mucho
más dinero de hecho con masacre está
pidiendo también a pedido ese fondo